[Musik]
regierungen müssen sich heute mit dem
wandel auseinandersetzen den die
technologie mit sich bringt die
veränderten erwartungen und
anforderungen der bürger an
servicestandards haben dazu geführt dass
regierungen weltweit nach neuen
definitionen für design und
bereitstellung suchen müssen jackson
verfolgt wichtige regierungen auf der
ganzen welt in der hoffnung antworten
darauf zu finden wie die regierungen von
morgen aussehen werden wie sie
spitzenleistungen erbringen und warum
erlebnisse vielleicht der schlüssel sind
um den wert hinter dem engagement der
bürger in der regierung zu erschließen
sex ist eine idee die in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten geboren wurde um das
versprechen der erbringung von
regierungs dienstleistungen zu erfüllen
und sie in ein erlebnis zu verwandeln
das modell entwickelt sich nun langsam
zu einer vorlage die weltweit eingesetzt
werden kann um eine exzellente
dienstleistungserbringung in der
regierung zu schaffen
hören sie eine sammlung von globalen
perspektiven die sowohl auf dem
öffentlichen als auch aus dem privaten
sektor kommen die meinungen der gäste in
diesem dokumentarfilm basieren zu einem
großen teil auf ihren erfahrungen in der
zusammenarbeit mit regierungen und den
schlüsselpositionen in denen regierungen
und der private sektor
aufeinandertreffen ein blick auf eine
der größten chancen die vor uns liegen
und auch auf einige der
herausforderungen denen sich regierungen
in den nächsten jahren stellen müssen
sechs neu ist die geschichte des großen
traums von exzellenz der veränderung von
wahrnehmungen und der schaffung einer
besseren zukunft für regierungs
dienstleistungen weltweit
mein name ist ihnen kam danke dass sie
mich auf dieser reise begleiten
[Musik]
wenn sie sich den aktuellen stand des
erfahrungsbereich der regierung ansehen
gibt es nicht wirklich einen standard
jeder auf der welt macht die dinge
anders und es gibt einen einfluss der
verschiedenen branchen auf die erfahrung
der regierung und in einigen teilen der
welt wird die regierung durch den
einzelhandel diktiert und wir stellen
einen vergleich zwischen einzelhandels
dienstleistungen und regierungs
dienstleistungen an was innerhalb der
regierung geschieht ist auch eine
nachwirkung dessen wie andere branchen
ihre kunden und ihren kundenstamm
bedienen die regierungen auf der ganzen
welt versuchen sich an verschiedene
dinge anzupassen und in zeiten
politischer instabilität wechsel der
regierungen ändern sich die prioritäten
der regierungen
[Musik]
lassen sie uns mit john aiken teil
sprechen ich sprach mit journalisten
über seine erfahrungen und didier bei
regierungen auf der ganzen welt
gesammelt hat jetzt arbeitet johnson mit
regierungen von asien über den mittleren
osten bis nach amerika und in europa und
er kennt den puls der regierungen und
die herausforderungen vor denen
regierungen stehen donovan ist ein
großer verfechter des wandels als
professor als pädagoge und als
geschäftsinhaber seine gedanken sind
entscheidend um zu verstehen wohin wir
gehen sollten und was regierungen tun
sollten um fortschritte zu erzielen
[Musik]
eines der dinge die ich beobachte
während ich das privileg habe viele
verschiedene regierungen und städte auf
der ganzen welt zu besuchen ist die
erkenntnis dass die gemeinden heute viel
höhere erwartungen an die erbringung von
dienstleistungen haben wenn sie also ein
mitglied der community sind sind sie es
gewohnt verbraucher apps auf ihrem
smartphone zu nutzen wurde auf einer
website zu gehen und dann nutzen sie
einen regierungs dienst und der es nicht
annähernd so gut oder vielleicht ist er
nicht einmal digital wir spüren dass
dies nicht mehr länger akzeptabel ist
und müssen das spiel beschleunigen
eine teilnehmerin des programms ist weiß
man ich habe mit ihm darüber gesprochen
was die herausforderungen der regierung
sind und womit regierungen und die
veteranen gemeinde konfrontiert sind
besonders in den vereinigten staaten und
was ihre erfahrungen mit dem regierungs
dienst und dessen qualität sind die
hälfte der amerikaner kann den
unterschied zwischen einem google
suchergebnis und einer google anzeige
nicht erkennen wir brauchen eine bessere
daten kompetenz damit wir wissen was
zuverlässige quellen für fakten sind
tiemann rehn hatte in unesco lehrstuhl
für aiciti inne und ist außerdem
professor an der university in london
team bringt eine menge erfahrung mit
wenn es darum geht international an der
basis zu arbeiten und wie es um die
erfahrungen und dienstleistungen der
regierung in europa steht
in vielen ländern der welt haben die
menschen kein vertrauen in ihre
regierungen und ich spreche aus meiner
erfahrung in afrika sie sind oft bereit
den privaten sektor eher zu vertrauen
als regierungen ich denke also es gibt
einige wirklich interessante dinge in
diesem bereich aber wenn die menschen
den regierungen nicht vertrauen werden
sie nicht bereit seien sich auf diese
dienstleistungen einzulassen es sei denn
natürlich die regierung macht dies über
ihre digitalen systeme zwingend
erforderlich ich erinnere mich dass vor
ein paar jahren viele länder sagten wir
werden standardmäßig digital aber das
schließt automatisch diejenigen aus die
nicht digital sind menschen mit
behinderungen ältere menschen sie werden
durch jene umstellung staatlicher
dienstleistungen an den rand gedrängt es
sei denn es werden alternative
mechanismen eingeführt sie müssen also
tatsächlich servicezentren bereitstellen
zu denen die leute kommen können also
wird digital standardmäßig an den rand
gedrängt
marius prompt als leiterin der block
chain und leiterin der ki
partnerschaften für die regierung der
niederlande eine erstaunliche ressource
sie hat so viel wissen und informationen
weil sie mit anderen regierungen aus der
ganzen welt zusammenarbeitet als
leiterin von block chain und einigen
sehr kritischen programmen der regierung
der niederlande mal los weiß vor welchen
herausforderungen regierungen stehen
wenn es um die implementierung von
technologien geht
in den niederlanden hat die regierung
fünf schlüsseltechnologien wie block
chain karibik data cyber sicherheit und
5g ausgewählt wir werden in den
kommenden jahren weiter in diese
technologie investieren um die dienste
zu verbessern wir versuchen eine
menschen zentrierte anwendung zu bauen
das bedeutet auch dass wir viele leute
haben die sich mit den risiken dieser
neuen technologien auseinandersetzen zum
beispiel nutzt die regierung bereits
eine menge ki in ihren diensten aber
natürlich gibt es auch das risiko der
diskriminierung aus diesem grund hat das
justizministerium eine richtlinie für
alle staatlichen dienste eingeführt die
neue technologien wie künstliche
intelligenz nutzen
ich habe auch mit dem leiter der
residenz der estnischen regierung
gesprochen und vater arbeitet seit
vielen jahren für die regierung ist lanz
und er bringt eine menge erfahrung mit
wenn es um die arbeit mit startups die
arbeit mit internationalen gremien
internationalen regierungen geht
unterteilte einige wirklich kritische
einblicke wenn es um erfahrungen mit der
regierung geht und was hat es mit dem
residence programm auf sich und warum
ist es ein so großartiges beispiel für
die schaffung einer nahtlosen
regierungserfahrung die für jedes land
egal welcher größe einen enormen
mehrwert darstellt
der unterschied zwischen den regierungs
diensten in der eu in asien und in den
usa ist sehr groß und die eu hat hier
einige ähnlichkeiten aber wenn man sich
konservative länder anschaut die
vielleicht nicht so viel vertrauen in
die regierung haben oder in die
regierung die ihre daten sicher
aufbewahrt was auch sehr wichtig ist
dann können sich diese dienste nicht
entwickeln wenn man sich länder wie
indien anschaut die ebenfalls ein
identitäts programm einführen aber 1,3
milliarden im vergleich zu 1,3 millionen
in estland ist schon eine etwas andere
herausforderung
[Musik]
island ist eines der grössten beispiele
dass genutzt wird wenn es darum geht
dass die regierung technologie einsetzt
und effizienz indem schafft was die
regierung tut ich habe mit dem ceo der
regierung von estland institut
gesprochen wir sprechen darüber welche
herausforderungen zu meistern hatte und
wir die regierungsarbeit aus ethischer
sicht sieht
[Musik]
unser haupt ansatz ist dass dienste so
weit wie möglich unsichtbar zu machen
konzentrieren wir uns nicht auf
interaktionen sondern darauf einen wert
zu liefern der wert ist also zum
beispiel dass wir die einhaltung der
vorschriften sicherstellen daher bitten
wir den unternehmer um eine art bericht
auch wenn wir ihn online fragen und ich
will damit sagen dass wir wenn wir es
aus dieser perspektive betrachten oft
sehen dass wir diese einzelnen
interaktionen nicht als dienste
entwerfen müssen wir können viele
onlinedienste buchstäblich loswerden
indem wir dinge weg automatisieren
einer der ersten ansätze ist dass eltern
von neugeborenen kein elterngeld
beantragen müssen es wird ihnen
automatisch zugeteilt worden war wir
bauen es für unternehmen auf das wenn
unternehmen einverstanden sind
umzustimmen die regierung zugang zu den
finanziellen aufzeichnungen hat die
gleichen daten die sowieso digital sind
dann werden wir sie nie mit einem
bericht nerven nicht versteuern nicht
für beschäftigung nicht für statistiken
nicht für jahresberichte und so weiter
all diese dinge können die unternehmen
jetzt online erledigen warum stören wir
sie noch mit einem schritt
[Musik]
es gibt definitiv ausreißer und es gibt
definitiv länder die eine solide
anstrengung in die richtung machen um
das engagement der regierung der vr für
die initiative government experience
vollständig zu verstehen die einen
präzedenzfall in der erbringung von
regierungs dienstleistungen schafft habe
ich mit jemandem gesprochen der diese
bemühungen im büro des premierministers
in den vr leitet mohammed bin thalia
[Musik]
in der vergangenheit lag der fokus mehr
darauf wie wir die dienste in bezug auf
prozesse aufbauen in bezug auf die
umwandlung von manuellen diensten in
automatisch und papierloser customers
allerdings suchen die kunden heute nach
diensten die sich mehr an ihren
erfahrungen in anderen teilen der welt
orientieren
mit denen sie vertraut sind
sie würden gerne sehen dass staatliche
dienstleistungen auf ähnliche oder sogar
bessere weise erbracht werden
[Musik]
johnny ist der ceo der majid al fahim
group in den vereinigten arabischen
emiraten die matte altheim group ist
eine der größten gruppen die den
einzelhandel im nahen osten leitet alert
halte eine menge kritischer einsichten
wie der einzelhandel die regierung
beeinflusst wie regierungen vom
einzelhandel lernen können alle hin
arbeitet auch für das
weltwirtschaftsforum und verschiedene
regierungen und gremien um ideen und
initiativen zu entwickeln
die regierungen weltweit betreffen
die vierte industrielle revolution ist
eine realität an sich und ich würde
sagen es ist sehr wichtig dass diese
veränderungsrate im inneren mindestens
gleich wenn nicht schneller ist als die
veränderungsrate im äußeren sie
ermöglicht es uns mit einigen der
endemischen probleme umzugehen mit denen
wir früher nicht umgehen konnten es
liegt nun an uns unserer generation von
führungskräften dafür zu sorgen dass wir
dies in die chance verwandeln die es
tatsächlich ist und dafür zu sorgen dass
wir nachhaltiges wirtschaftswachstum die
schaffung von arbeitsplätzen und die
bessere integration unserer
gesellschaften in der welt vorantreiben
können
[Musik]
war die handy ist ceo eines auf
basierenden unternehmens das sich auf
die versicherungsbranche konzentriert
aber er bringt viele kritische
einsichten in die idee von 6 1 6 in den
letzten vielleicht fünf bis acht jahren
sind die kunden nicht mehr bereit
verzögerungen oder mangelnde transparenz
zu tolerieren oder nicht zu wissen was
der nächste schritt ist oder gar
schlecht behandelt zu werden historisch
gesehen war die wirtschaft in den 70er
jahren eher produktorientiert dann kamen
die 80er und 90er jahre und jetzt bewegt
sie sich mehr in richtung einer
beziehungs wirtschaft wir leben in der
erlebnis wirtschaft und ich denke das
ist etwas das sie immer mehr und mehr
sehen werden wenn sie über die
anstrengungen nachdenken die wir alle
zusammen unternehmen der private sektor
der öffentliche sektor und wie wir alle
versuchen alles auf dem kunden
auszurichten stellen wir sicher dass der
kunde tatsächlich im mittelpunkt steht
und wie können wir tatsächlich vom
standpunkt der regierung außer dieser
lebensqualität beitragen dazu beitragen
dass sie all die unsicherheiten die
damit einhergehen weg nehmen und ihnen
die möglichkeit geben sich auf das zu
konzentrieren worauf sie sich
konzentrieren möchten nämlich einen
service der erstens um sie herum
kuratiert ist und zweitens dass er da
ist wenn sie ihn brauchen und denken sie
tatsächlich darüber nach was der kunde
beziehungsweise bürger braucht und nicht
was die regierung braucht sehr lange
zeit haben sich die regierungen darauf
konzentriert dienste zu entwerfen oder
diese entwürfe so zu implementieren dass
sie den regierungen aus verschiedenen
perspektiven passen und ich denke was
sie hier sehen ist eigentlich ein
totaler unterschied
ich habe mit der regierung in athen und
dem leiter des servicecenters gesprochen
dias und service zentren haben die idee
der service bereitstellung komplett
verändert indem sie verschiedene
anbieter und mehr als 300
dienstleistungen an einem ort
zusammenführen es hat die art und weise
wie die regierung dienstleistungen auf
der ebene von service centern erbringt
radikal verändert
[Musik]
traditionelle wege sind nicht mehr
geeignet um unsere dienstleistungen zu
erbringen und einen gewissen
zufriedenheitsgrad zu erreichen aber wir
wissen auch dass es nicht nur um
technologien geht es geht auch um
organisationsstrukturen
es geht um menschliche ressourcen und
wir versuchen ein geeignetes umfeld zu
schaffen um unsere dienstleistungen
effektiv und effizient für unsere bürger
zu erbringen
worauf die regierung einen unglaublichen
wert gelegt hatte ist die erkenntnis
dass jeder mensch anders ist und ein
großartiges erlebnis ist auch nicht
etwas das völlig reibungslos abläuft wie
zum beispiel das buchen eines
flugtickets es ist nicht so schwierig zu
sagen zu welchem bahnhof man muss zu
welcher zeit von wo aus man abwehrte und
wie viele passagiere mitfahren das ist
ein sehr automatisierter prozess der
fast keine variationen aufweist aber
wenn sie versuchen ihren namen zu ändern
und ihre optionen sind nicht verfügbar
oder wenn sie versuchen
gesundheitsdienstleistungen zu
beanspruchen und sie haben zwei kinder
eines ist ihr leibliches das anderes
adoptiert das sind die arten von
einzigartigen situationen die wenn
organisationen in der lage sind damit
effektiv umzugehen den menschen ein
wirklich gutes gefühl geben denn es gibt
ihnen das gefühl dass sie tatsächlich
verstehen dass es persönliche
anforderungen gibt die die bürger an sie
haben
wenn sie zu hause sitzen wie ist ihr
gefühl gegenüber den dienstleistungen
die sie von der regierung erhalten
machen sie sich sorgen darüber etwas zu
verpassen oder zu vergessen ihre
rechnungen zu bezahlen ihre nebenkosten
abrechnungen oder fühlen sie sich wohl
weil sie wissen dass es automatisch über
ihren digitalen assistenten abgewickelt
wird
diese art von niveau und diese art von
erfahrung ist das was wir anstreben wo
ein kunde sich keine sorgen machen muss
weil alles im hintergrund in seinem
namen läuft
die inanspruchnahme staatlicher
dienstleistungen irgendwo auf der welt
ist normalerweise mit dem gedanken an
bürokratie und viel papierkram verbunden
ich denke was sie anders ist ist dass es
einen unglaublichen fokus darauf gab
sicherzustellen dass der schmerz und die
reibung die normalerweise mit der
jährlichen erneuerung von diensten
verbunden sind weggenommen wurden ob das
nun der wechsel ihres fahrzeugs ist der
fast vollständig digital abläuft ob das
der personalausweis ist oder ob es nur
um das bezahlen ihres parkplatz es über
ihr mobiltelefon geht alles ist
miteinander verknüpft und das schöne ist
dass es eine einzige app gibt auf die
sie dann zugreifen können egal ob
krankenhäuser bestattungsunternehmen
oder behörden alle informationen sind an
einem ort untergebracht
[Musik]
einer umfrage zufolge sind drei viertel
der cios der meinung dass das
kundenerlebnis sehr wichtig für ihr
unternehmen ist aber in der regierung
gibt es keine solche umfrage ich weiß
nicht wie viele führungskräfte in der
regierung denken dass das kundenerlebnis
oberste priorität hat aber ich sage
ihnen dass es zehn millionen
regierungsmitarbeiter gibt und dass es
nicht für alle oberste priorität hat
[Musik]
sagen wir also sie müssen in einen ort
gehen sie müssen an einen physischen ort
gehen wie ist die erfahrung wenn sie
dort ankommen ist es überfüllt und
chaotisch wissen sie was zu tun ist
bekommen sie einen guten kundenservice
sprechen sie mit menschen die gut
informiert sind und wenn sie selbst
schwierigkeiten haben ihnen die
informationen zu beschaffen haben sie
zugang zur informations mitteln die
ihnen als mitglied der gemeinschaft
helfen können ich glaube die regierungen
beginnen jetzt über den gesamten
lebenszyklus eines prozesses
nachzudenken zum beispiel um eine kopie
ihrer geburtsurkunde zu erhalten wenn
sie einen antrag für eine genehmigung
einreichen möchten die gerade so eine
gängige staat oder regierungs aufgabe
ist sollte es nicht so schwer sein wie
es heute ist die leute freuen sich nicht
darauf und die erfahrung sollte besser
sein sie sollten in der lage sein eine
genehmigung online zu beantragen ohne
dass sie irgendwo hingehen und eine
nummer ziehen müssen und den halben tag
in der behörde sitzen
in den vereinigten arabischen emiraten
konzentrieren wir uns auf das
kundenerlebnis auf basis ihrer
lebensumstände wenn der kunde zum
beispiel ein neugeborenes baby hat
betrachten wir das als einen punkt im
leben an dem er staatliche
dienstleistungen rund ums neue baby
benötigt deshalb haben wir begonnen die
sache aus der perspektive der bündelung
zu betrachten anstatt dass ein kunde
also nach schaut welche behörden oder
behörden servicecenter er aufsuchen
sollte weiß einfach welches paket er
haben möchte ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel
für einen der dienste die wir haben er
heißt mabrouk majak was glückwunsch zu
ihrem neugeborenen bedeutet und es hat
mehr als sieben dienste in einem schritt
und mehr als fünf zahlungen in einer
zahlung gebündelt und alles was mit
diesem neugeborenen zu tun hat bekommen
sie jetzt mit diesem wandel innerhalb
von drei stunden
wir bewegen uns jetzt von einem
meilenstein einkaufs modell zu einem non
stop shop modell in unseren service
centern bieten wir unseren bürgern
reaktive dienste an aber jetzt haben wir
ein neues projekt gestartet das sich
mein wachstum ein regierungsprojekt
nennt und es geht um die bereitstellung
proaktiver dienste für unsere bürger
dafür sind wir bereit beta weitgehend zu
nutzen um die erwartungen unserer bürger
vorherzusagen und regierungsintern
versuchen wir auch die unternehmen in
diesen prozess einzubinden
[Musik]
als ergebnis einer sich wirklich schnell
verändernden welt ändern sich auch die
erwartungen der bürger die bürger
erwarten heute ein anderes niveau an
service auf regierungsebene die
erwartungen sind eine kombination aus
dem was sie im privaten sektor im
einzelhandel und im gesundheitswesen
sehen und das führt zu einem allgemeinen
bedürfnis der bürger wenn sie so wollen
nach service exzellenz die bürger von
heute sie und ich wir alle nutzen
smartphones und technologie um
entscheidungen zu treffen um auf dienste
zuzugreifen und es ist sehr verbreitet
einfach zu erwarten dass jeder service
auf einem mobiltelefon verfügbar sein
sollte er sollte auf einem mobilen gerät
verfügbar sein aber nicht alle
regierungen waren in der lage services
von einem servicecenter ins internet zu
übertragen
[Musik]
bei den meisten sogenannten governance
agenden geht es in wirklichkeit darum
dass regierungen den menschen dienste
durch technologie zur verfügung stellen
so sehen wir webseiten der regierung auf
die sie zugreifen können formulare zum
ausfüllen von pässen oder lizenzen oder
zum bezahlen von steuern das ist eine
wirklich interessante veränderung der
managementstruktur früher hatten die
regierungen viele beamte viele leute die
für sie arbeiteten um den papierkram zu
erledigen
jetzt wurde der aufwand und die last
wieder auf die bürger übertragen es ist
wie in den alten tagen wenn sie an einem
meeting teilnehmen sollten schickte
ihnen jemand den ganzen papierkram im
voraus sie mussten nichts tun sie haben
nur den papierkram gelesen und zum
treffen mitgenommen jetzt werden ihnen
die daten digital per e mail oder über
ein anderes online-system zugeschickt
oder es wird sogar von ihnen erwartet
dass sie online gehen um diese formulare
selbst herunter zu laden sie dann zu
lesen und sie dann vielleicht
auszudrucken weil sie sie vielleicht zur
besprechung mitnehmen müssen das ist
also eine verlagerung der arbeit von
regierungen zu bürgern oder von
organisationen zu mitarbeitern ich hasse
es mich jeden tag auf drei oder vier
verschiedenen websites anmelden zu
müssen um informationen zu erhalten
während sie mir einfach in einer anderen
form geschickt werden könnten die
standard rhetorik ist natürlich dass es
für regierungen und bürger viel
einfacher ist bei wichtigen dingen die
sie tun müssen zu interview und dass er
zweifellos seine vorteile es ist jetzt
sehr einfach einen passantrag online zu
stellen oder ihre steuerformulare online
einzureichen der zweite punkt ist jedoch
und ich werde das beispiel unseres
eigenen digitalen regierungs dienstes
verwenden es gibt viele großartige dinge
auf golf dort uk wenn sie auf der
website der regierung etwas über ein
ministerium oder dessen aufgaben
herausfinden möchten ist dies fast
unmöglich und ich denke das ist ein
hinweis darauf dass es einen unterschied
zwischen der erbringung von regierungs
dienstleistungen und der beziehung
zwischen regierungen und bürgern und der
offenheit und transparenz in diesem
bereich gibt
[Musik]
heute denke ich dass die bürger
mitgestalter einer regierungserfahrung
sind es gibt eine möglichkeit für jeden
von uns partner zu sein und dabei zu
helfen dinge zu erledigen eine größere
offenheit zu erreichen städte
progressiver zu machen und mehr
werkzeuge wie die zusammenarbeit zu
erlangen die es insbesondere den
mitgliedern der gemeinschaft erlauben an
allem teilzunehmen von der
entscheidungsfindung bis hin zu design
sitzungen und sogar der entwicklung von
lösungen es gibt einige sehr
interessante experimente mit der
gemeinschaft kofinanzierung
identifizierung von geldern aus dem
öffentlichen und privaten sektor um
projekte zu realisieren die aufgrund der
abhängigkeit von rein öffentlichen
geldern nur schwer in gang zu bringen
waren wenn eine regierung daten zur
verfügung stellt und das community
mitglied sagt hey ich könnte eine lösung
mit diesen daten bauen wow das ist eine
tolle beziehung das ist eine tolle
partnerschaft wir haben jetzt
software-ingenieure die antreten können
um interessante lösungen zu erstellen
oder um daten sinnvoll zu nutzen und die
analysen zu liefern die den
entscheidungsträgern helfen bessere
entscheidungen zu treffen das ist eine
beziehung für die wir noch nie die
werkzeuge hatten um sie zu realisieren
eine gute demokratische
regierungserfahrung ist kein
zuschauersport sondern etwas an dem sie
teilnehmen
der staat washington ist eine meiner
bevorzugten
leistungsorientierten organisationen es
gibt etwas das sich reese als washington
net jeder einzelne kennzahl über die
landesregierung ist online verfügbar
inklusive analysen um mehr details zu
erhalten und wenn der gouverneur eine
ergebnis besprechung veranstaltet ist
die öffentlichkeit eingeladen
es wird live online gestreamt aber sie
beziehen auch einen oder zwei oder drei
kunden in jedes einzelne meeting ein
wenn es also um die entwicklung der
jugend geht gibt es tatsächlich
jugendliche die der regierung ein
feedback geben wie sich die dienste
verbessern wo sie im meer verbesserung
brauchen das ist also ein großartiges
beispiel auf staatlicher ebene und im
moment sammeln 90 prozent der websites
unserer bundesbehörden kundenfeedback
und versuchen sich interaktiv zu
verbessern mein fazit ist dass es
wirklich interessantes was heute in der
welt passiert die menge an daten die
täglich generiert wird ist einfach
überwältigend doch wenn sie mit vielen
unternehmen sprechen mit der regierung
mit dem privaten sektor mit großen
unternehmen werden diese ihnen sagen
dass sie schlechte daten haben probleme
mit der qualität dass es lücken in den
daten gibt da gibt es ein problem
es gibt viele als systeme und daten die
da draußen sind die ziemlich schwierig
zu erschließen und an die oberfläche zu
bringen sind wenn sie etwas auf der
grünen wiese bauen ist es viel einfacher
das von a bis z zu tun aber die wahrheit
ist dass viele regierungsabteilungen
riesige altlasten an
informationssystemen haben die mit
traditionellen prozessen verbunden sind
die schwierigkeit besteht also darin
diese in einem format zusammen zu fassen
in dem der kunde keine unebenheiten
spürt es ist als würde man einen
einkaufswagen über ein bahngleis
schieben ein sehr holpriger erlebnis und
was sie versuchen ist all diese knoten
aus der erfahrung heraus zu lösen
[Musik]
für alle dienste brauchen sie eine art
identität aber das klingt als gäbe es
nur eine identität und ich nehme an sie
haben mehrere die sie verwenden ich habe
beispielsweise eine identität mit der
ich mich bei meinem google konto
anmelden eine andere als für
behördendienste ich hoffe diese
digitalen identitäten mehrere
identitäten gehören mir und werden von
mir kontrolliert
der staat indiana hat vor kurzem einen
single sign-on geschaffen so dass ich
meine park genehmigung und meinen
führerschein zertifizierungen alle
staatlichen aktivitäten unter einer idee
abrufen kann damit ich meine
informationen nicht ständig neu eingeben
muss ist das eine wunderbare art von one
stop shop aber wir sind noch weit davon
entfernt dass wir in der lage sind von
der bundesebene über die länder ebene
bis hin zur lokalen ebene mit einer
einzigen identitäts agieren und ich
denke es lohnt sich hier vorsichtig zu
sein denn eine einzige identität in der
regierung birgt das risiko dass sie
gehackt werden könnte und wenn dies
durch den privaten sektor geschieht hat
die regierung nicht die kontrolle und
kann sie nicht in der weise überwachen
wie es vielleicht notwendig wäre so ist
zum beispiel in den usa zum reisen die
transportation security administration
für die ausstellung vom tsc projects
verantwortlich so dass sie mich
überprüfen und sich dann in einem verein
wechseln kann nun es gibt auch eine
privatwirtschaftliche einrichtung die
das tut was ist die grundlegende rolle
der regierung sollte es die regierung
sein die sagt wer in einem flugzeug
einsteigen kann und sicher reisen darf
und wer nicht
wenn sie der regierung ihre gesamte
identität überlassen was könnte sie
damit anstellen ich vergleiche das oft
mit den geschehnissen in ruanda wo der
einsatz älterer digitaler technologien
zum beispiel des radios viele teile des
dortigen völkermordes effizienter machte
wenn also eine regierung die identität
eines jeden menschen kennt und weiß wo
er wohnt und alles über ihn weiß was
kann sie dann mit diesen informationen
anfangen bei migranten geht es sehr auf
den fragen wie zum beispiel ob
qualifikationen die in einem land
gewonnen wurden mit denen in einem
anderen kompatibel sind stellen sie sich
also vor jeder hätte eine digitale
identität die er mitnehmen könnte so
dass sie wenn sie von kenia nach
südafrika oder von haiti nach brasilien
ziehen tatsächlich ihre identität
mitnehmen können ich denke dass eröffnet
wirklich spannende möglichkeiten nicht
nur für migranten sondern auch für
regierungen wenn wir globale
vereinbarungen darüber treffen könnten
was ihre parameter und was die
berechtigungsnachweise in der digitalen
identität bedeuten könnte dass wirklich
von vorteil sein
[Musik]
es wird also nicht die eine technologie
sein die das identitäts thema lösen wird
es wird eine kombination sein und in
diesem moment versuchen wir wirklich
herauszufinden wie wir eine digitale
identität mit datenschutzfreundlichen
technologien wie zero knowledge proofs
oder mode party computation kombinieren
können ich denke das ist ein wirklich
interessanter bereich der auf
internationaler ebene erforscht werden
sollte
[Musik]
da wir in island glauben dass die
digitale identität das rückgrat von
allem ist jede person sollte eine
identität haben die ihr physisch und
digital entspricht so kommuniziert jeder
ist mit der regierung unter verwendung
seiner digitalen identität was bedeutet
dass er alles von kontoauszügen
übersteuern bis hin zu registrierungen
der kind geburt unter verwendung der
digitalen identität erledigt und wir
können uns unser leben nicht mehr anders
vorstellen
diese lernerfahrung erlebnisse im fokus
zu haben war tatsächlich schön für uns
als estnische regierung ich will hier
ganz ehrlich sein ich glaube wir waren
in unseren anfangsjahren sehr technisch
und ingenieurs mäßig orientiert vor
allem in dem sinne wie viel besser wie
viel effizienter wir sein können wenn
wir die dinge funktional aufbauen und
zum beispiel dienst der online stellen
ungeachtet der kundenerfahrung jetzt
kommen wir zu dem punkt der es auf die
nächste stufe gebracht hat natürlich
muss die kundenerfahrung im vordergrund
stehen denn sonst haben wir keine leute
die die dienste nutzen und so
entwickelte es sich natürlich weit über
fragen des schönen sauberen design
seiner online umgebung hinaus unser
hauptaugenmerk liegt darauf wie wir den
prozess die arbeit der regierung zur
besten erfahrungen machen können und in
vielen fällen geht es für uns darum wie
wir abläufe radikal vereinfachen können
denn die beste erfahrung zumindest was
studien angeht ist wenn es gar keine
gibt sondern einfach passiert als erste
ist es sehr schwer ratschläge zu
physischen service centern zu geben denn
für uns bedeutete der digitale weg sie
weitestgehend loszuwerden
es gibt die steuerbehörde die einen
physischen standort hat und vielleicht
die post aber ansonsten wenn wir über
staatliche dienstleistungen sprechen
sind diese zu 99 prozent online wenn sie
keinen zugang zum digitalen haben egal
auf welche weise weil sie keinen
internet keinen strom haben werden sie
durch die bereitstellung digitaler
dienste weiter an den rand gedrängt das
klassische beispiel ist die idee der
smart cities ich sage oft dass allein
das wort smart cities eigentlich
impliziert dass dörfer ziemlich dumm
sind eine der größten herausforderungen
besteht also darin dass man in einem
kleinen ort nicht dasselbe liefern kann
wie in einem dicht besiedelten gebiet
mit voller konnektivität deshalb ist es
so wichtig in erster linie zugang zu
haben
und nicht alle unsere bürger sind
technisch versiert deshalb brauchen wir
service center in allen teilen unseres
landes außerdem haben wir busse diese
busse sind speziell mit verschiedenen
technologien ausgestattet wir haben
diese busse in die abgelegenen gebiete
geschickt in denen wir keine as a
service zentren haben um unsere bürger
zu bedienen und wir haben auch
freiwillige helfer
der menschliche faktor innerhalb des
regierungs erlebnis ist ein primärer
faktor aus allen perspektiven würde ich
sagen ob es sich also um eine kundin
perspektive handelt oder um die
perspektive eines regierungsmitarbeiters
selbst die mitarbeiter die an der
erbringung von regierungs
dienstleistungen arbeiten haben wir nach
ihrem zufriedenheits niveau befragt wir
haben uns angesehen wie sie verstehen
was kunden wollen deshalb haben wir eine
reihe von schulungen durchgeführt es ist
ein training zur kundenzufriedenheit bei
dem wir uns die mitarbeiter an der
frontlinie ansehen die die
dienstleistungen erbringen wir haben sie
darin geschult wie sie ihre geschäfte so
führen können dass der kunde zufriedener
ist und gleichzeitig haben wir uns die
vorgesetzten dieser staatlichen
servicecenter angesehen die wir in den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten zentrum
für kundenzufriedenheit nennen und wir
haben sie darin geschult wie man ein
team von kundenzufriedenheits
beauftragten beaufsichtigt
ich bin nicht dafür die physischen
standorte vollständig abzuschaffen denn
wir sehen dass in einigen regionen des
landes diese die einzige form der
kommunikation bieten die einige dieser
menschen tatsächlich wahrnehmen können
und sie genießen diese form der
kommunikation
sie gehen gerne zur post aber in bezug
auf das stadtleben zum finanzamt gehen
zu müssen um dort drei stunden lang auf
den papierstapel warten zu müssen das
sollte abgeschafft werden
[Musik]
die art und weise der gestaltung von
regierungs dienstleistungen ist wirklich
klar wir brauchen eine vorlage für
exzellenz wir brauchen etwas das sich
leicht anpassen lässt und einfach
eingesetzt werden kann wenn ein land zum
beispiel ein exzellenz modell hat ist
dieses modell in der lage über
verschiedene gruppen über verschiedene
abteilungen und ministerien hinweg
repliziert zu werten dass es genau das
was gebraucht wird dass die ex programm
in den vereinigten arabischen emiraten
ist ein hervorragendes beispiel dafür
exzellente regierungs dienstleistungen
haben für die regierung der vr oberste
priorität dinge wie das treten der
rankings von staatlichen service centern
ist den den vg nicht sehr ungewöhnlich
und das ist die art wie die regierung
das land führt die exportkredite die ex
wurde mit der vision und dem verstand
geschaffen die aufmerksamkeit der
menschen die an dienstleistungen
arbeiten zu lenken unabhängig von der
art der kunden oder der persona des
kunden wir müssen uns auch die erfahrung
des kunden konzentrieren wer ist nun
teil der 6
es könnte also der private sektor seien
investoren startups unternehmer wer teil
der gx plattform sein könnte hat mehrere
aspekte wir haben das government
services forum dass führungskräfte aus
der ganzen welt an einen tisch bringt um
über government services zu diskutieren
wir haben die gags online plattform die
die wissensbasis teilt die regierungen
auf der ganzen welt die kundenerfahrung
verbessern wir haben auch die ex
gespräche die gags gespräche
konzentrieren sich darauf vordenker aus
verschiedenen bereichen zusammen zu
bringen um über kunden erfahrungen zu
sprechen sei es die digitale erfahrung
oder auch die physische erfahrung oder
sogar erfahrungen die keinen touchpoint
haben wenn sie also zum beispiel zu
hause sitzen wie fühlen sie sich mit dem
was ihr von der regierung bekommen haben
sie angst etwas zu verpassen oder zu
vergessen ihre rechnungen ihre
nebenkosten abrechnungen zu bezahlen
oder sind sie entspannt weil sie wissen
dass alles automatisch verarbeitet wird
sind eine beeindruckende nation haben
den vorteil dass sie schnell wendig und
agil sind in der art und weise wie sie
initiativen angehen außerdem haben sie
eine führung die wirklich daran glaubt
digital zu werten und die vierte
industrielle revolution anzuführen ich
denke wenn man diese zutaten zusammen
fügt erhält man eine sehr einzigartige
umgebung aufgrund der plattform die
durch die investition in dieses
futuristische denken geschaffen wurde
es ist nicht nur ihre version und ihr
geräte sondern sie bauen dinge und tun
dinge ich habe diese dinge in dubai aus
erster hand erfahren können
zum beispiel ihr konzept rund um die
zukünftige polizeistation es ist ein
schönes erlebnis die menschen fühlen
sich sicher und vieles davon geschieht
durch den einsatz digitaler technologien
unterstützung durch die richtigen
ressourcen per video-konferenz was sich
unglaublich fand sie sehen eine menge
experimente und prototypen sie sehen
sehr kühne projekte alles von smart
dubai bis hin zur papierlosen
gesellschaft wodurch die kosten der
regierung geringer und die daten genauer
werden all die vorteile die wir erwarten
würden einer der größten vorteile für
die umwelt ist der verzicht auf papier
sie tun es sie demonstrieren es sie
experimentieren sie helfen anderen
gemeinden und städten und regierungen
auf der ganzen welt zu sehen was möglich
ist um diese erkenntnisse mit der welt
zu teilen möchte ich dass sie dinge wie
das gx forum schaffen das zu einer
globalen plattform wird und zu sagen hey
welche möglichkeiten einer
regierungserfahrung gibt es wir müssen
in der lage sein kanäle zu schaffen die
dieser best practices die dinge die gut
laufen und vielleicht über die lehren
aus den dingen die nicht immer so gut
laufen aufnehmen und mit regierungen in
jeder ecke der welt teilen
ich denke also dass es wichtig ist dass
es ein internationales gespräch ist und
offen gesagt ein persönliches gespräch
denn wir sind alle beschäftigt wenn wir
versuchen uns per telefon oder webinar
zu treffen werden wir abgelenkt aber
wenn man sich physisch mit anderen
menschen trifft stellt man die art von
verbindungen her die anhalten und die es
uns erlauben den ball weiterzuspielen
unser denken weiter zu verfeinern und
uns gegenseitig herauszufordern dieses
gefühl von fast so etwas wie einem
gesunden verb unter gleichaltrigen wie
ich werde etwas zu sagen haben wenn ich
wieder mit dieser gruppe zusammenkommen
was habe ich getan was bringe ich auf
den tisch ich denke also das ist ein
echter wert den wir in dieser gruppe
sehen können
es ist wirklich notwendig experimente
innerhalb der eigenen organisation
durchzuführen aber ansonsten ist es
immer noch kompliziert diese
diskussionen mit anderen partnern zu
führen sie müssen also ein wenig
innerhalb ihrer eigenen organisation
testen und erforschen sie müssen ihre
mitarbeiter schulen es gibt kaum
vergleichbare projekte es ist also
wirklich wichtig zu lernen feste
koalitionen zu bilden und welche
vereinbarungen wir brauchen rechtliche
fragen rund um diese kooperationen die
regierungs modelle aufbauen können
[Musik]
natürlich ist es sehr schwierig unsere
ideen einfach so umzusetzen denn jedes
land hat seine eigenen kulturen sowohl
in bezug auf die tradition als auch auf
die umwelt und sie müssen sehen wie sie
in dieser umgebung herausgefordert
werden und wie sie diese probleme
während des implementierungsprozess
lösen
initiativen wie diese neigen oft dazu
die beste globale lösung finden zu
wollen aber diese ideen entwickeln sich
weiter die beziehungen zu den bürger
staaten entwickelt sich weiter die
technologie entwickelt sich weiter also
ein bisschen mehr denke ich selbstkritik
ist angebracht und nicht immer nur
positiv über einige der aktivitäten zu
reden denn technologie kann für gutes
und für schlechtes verwendet werden und
es geht darum wie unmittelbar diese im
interesse der bürger sind für mich sind
die bürger eigentlich wichtiger als die
regierungen regierungen sollten ihren
bürgern dienen
[Musik]
familie wir haben aus den erfahrungen
mit der präsident sie gelernt sich in
die lage des anwenders zu versetzen denn
wir sehen sehr oft dass genau das den
regierungsbeamten fehlt sie sitzen in
ihren zimmern und sprechen nicht mit den
anwendern sie verstehen die bedürfnisse
der anwender im zeitalter des
smartphones nicht und alter
privatwirtschaftlichen dienste die wir
eigentlich ständig konsumieren wir
dürfen von unseren regierungen nicht
erwarten dass sie hier hinterher hinken
wir glauben in island dass regierungen
niemals mit privaten unternehmen
konkurrieren können und das sollten sie
auch nicht aber regierungen sind
diejenigen die staatliche
dienstleistungen anbieten müssen es ist
also an der zeit tatsächlich mit den
trends mitzugehen damit was in der welt
passiert
die global ist aaa rating program das
globale sterne bewertungsprogramm ist
das erste seiner art das staatliche
dienstleistungszentren wie hotels
bewertet so wie sie in ein hotel gehen
und sehen dass dieses hotel ein fünf
sterne hotel ist und sie wissen was sie
von einem fünf sterne hotel erwarten
können so wurde das gleiche konzept auf
dienstleistungszentren der regierung
angewendet hasan hamit hat uns
angeleitet die regierung der vereinigten
arabischen emirate so effizient wie
banken zu machen und rund um die uhr zu
arbeiten wie flughäfen seitdem dieses
programm eingeführt wurde haben wir die
früchte dieses programms ernten können
indem wir gesehen haben dass sich das
kundenzufriedenheit zentrum in den
letzten acht jahren deutlich verbessert
hat
das edelman trust barometer stuft die
ivg sehr hoch ein die vereinigten
arabischen emirate haben ihre
regierungsdienste schon immer so
gestaltet dass sie eigentlich als
dienstleister für die gesellschaft
angesehen werden heute blicken die vag
nach vorne und sagen wir wollen noch
mehr noch besser werden ich möchte noch
kundenorientierter sein ich möchte
sicherstellen dass die dienstleistung in
meiner regierung nicht nur die besten
der welt sind sondern auch die
zufriedenstellenden für die menschen die
sie wählen um die besten der welt zu
sein müssen wir uns auch den spiegel
vorhalten und das ist etwas das die
leute sehen und von dem sie denken dass
die regierung mit gutem beispiel
vorangeht
diese liegen bei gesamten
[Musik]
die zukunft des dx programms durch das
büro des premierministers in den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten ist
stark es ist etwas das greifbar ist es
ist etwas das von jedem staatlichen
dienstleistungsprogramm auf der welt
entwickelt und übernommen werden kann
aber es braucht arbeit es braucht arbeit
denn die implementierung dieser dinge
ist komplex sie brauchen stakeholder die
sich auf diese dinge einigen sie
brauchen die zustimmung der menschen die
regierungen führen und das sind einige
der herausforderungen mit denen andere
regierungen konfrontiert werden könnten
wenn sie dieses programm einführen wir
leben in einer ära des umbruchs der sich
schnell ändernden erwartungen um die
welt zu einem besseren ort zu machen
müssen wir das spiel auf eine andere art
und weise spielen egal ob es sich um die
ex oder ein anderes programm auf ebene
der regierungsbehörden handelt es
braucht engagement es braucht das
engagement der führung dieser länder
diese abteilungen und gruppen
das ist also eine erstaunliche zeit es
gibt so viel potenzial und wir brauchen
zwei dinge wir müssen erstens zu hören
und zweitens handeln und wenn man diese
beiden dinge zusammen nimmt macht das
einen großen unterschied so hat in den
usa die veteranen verwaltung die
ehemalige militärangehörige betreut die
jetzt wieder im land sind eine umfrage
zur kundenzufriedenheit gestartet und es
stellte sich heraus dass menschen die an
der umfrage teilnahmen und feedback
haben viermal zufriedener mit der
regierung waren als andere wir wissen
jetzt noch nicht ob ein teil davon eine
stichproben verzerrung ist dass
diejenigen die sich dazu entschieden
haben an der umfrage teilzunehmen
zufriedener waren aber für mich sagt es
auch dass es einen unterschied macht
einfach nach feedback zu fragen wenn sie
die öffentlichkeit einbeziehen werden
die leute begeistert sein die stadt
santa monica in kalifornien hat einen
wohlfühl index sie haben dort
beschlossen dass der zweck dieser stadt
darin besteht das wohlergehen der
menschen zu unterstützen eines der dinge
die sie getan haben ist so genannte
social media sentiment mining so können
sie anhand der öffentlich zugänglichen
informationen auf facebook und twitter
erkennen welche stadtteile unter stress
stehen welche stadtteile geldsorgen
haben und wie die stadt wirklich etwas
dagegen tun kann wir haben jetzt eine
drogen behandlung in den gefängnissen
weil die mensch die aus den gefängnissen
kamen 1 120 mal höheres risiko hatten an
einer drogenüberdosis zu sterben als die
durchschnittliche person so können wir
jetzt interventionen in unseren
gefängnissen durchführen weil der
datensatz uns erlaubt hat gezielt zu
arbeiten als bürger sich beteiligten und
der regierung helfen konnten zu
entscheiden wohin das geld geht als die
bürger die entscheidungen treffen
konnten gab es mehr investitionen in
gesundheit mehr investitionen in bildung
und einige der ersten städte die dieses
instrument einsetzten zeigten in 15
jahren eine geringere
kindersterblichkeit ich denke wir werden
ein viel höheres vertrauen in die
regierung haben denn mit all diesen
neuen möglichkeiten die öffentlichkeit
einzubeziehen gibt es ungenutzte ideen
und ressourcen und das potenzial die
regierung wirklich viel besser zu machen
als sie es je war
wir planen personalisierte dienste für
unsere bürger zu implementieren aus
jedem land von jedem ort und ohne hürden
und umso zugänglich und verfügbar zu
sein müssen wir auch neue technologien
implementieren maschinelles lernen die
learning und andere technologien jetzt
haben wir ein gemeinsames cloud
basiertes system für die
dokumentenablage implementiert das uns
hilft die kosten für die bereitstellung
dieser dienste zu reduzieren und die
prozesse zu optimieren
[Musik]
die gruppe für die regierungen der
zukunft werden sich mehr auf den zweck
und weniger auf dienstleistungen
konzentrieren künstliche intelligenz
maschinelles lernen wird die meisten der
zu erbringenden dienstleistungen
übernehmen wir werden uns mehr darauf
konzentrieren über unsere zukunft
nachzudenken regierungen werden viel
mehr zeit haben und mehr vorsicht walten
lassen wenn es um die lebensqualität
geht viele der probleme die wir heute
kennen viele der themen die sie heute zu
lösen versuchen wird es in zehn jahren
nicht mehr geben wir alle werden in
unseren menschlichen fähigkeiten
unterstützt werden wir werden in der
lage sein mehr für weniger zu tun aber
wir werden auch in der lage sein und
tatsächlich auf die bereiche zu
konzentrieren in denen wir den größten
unterschied machen und den größten
einfluss ausüben können nicht in bezug
auf die kleinen dinge die um uns herum
passieren sondern in bezug auf die
bereicherung des lebens und wie wir
kontinuierlich fortschritt vorantreiben
können
ich glaube dass ki definitiv den
nächsten zyklus der großen revolution in
der technologie bestimmen wird und was
sie damit machen können sind eine menge
produkte und dienstleistungen die in der
vergangenheit nicht möglich waren aber
ich glaube nicht dass der algorithmus
eines tages empfindungsfähigkeit und
aufwacht und dann herausfindet dass
menschen ausgerottet werden müssen
lassen sie uns pragmatisch und
realistisch sein und machen sie sich
keine sorgen über den 2 teil der teil
der ki der wirklich aufregend ist ist am
hilfreichsten für firmen anwender oder
unternehmensmitarbeiter der erste ist
das konzept des digitalen zwillings das
konzept des digitalen zwillings besteht
darin dass ein assistenz seite an seite
mit dem menschen arbeitet um die
qualität der arbeit zu verbessern indem
alle banalen manuellen aufgaben an die
ki und die automatisierung übertragen
werden damit der mensch sich tatsächlich
auf die dinge konzentrieren kann auf die
er sich konzentrieren sollte nicht auf
das abheften von papieren nicht auf das
durchforsten von dingen und den versuch
1000 seiten zu indizieren was alles von
maschinen erledigt werden sollte der
digitale zwilling sollte diese workflow
automatisierung für den menschen
bereitstellen um effektiver und
effizienter zu werden viele der dienste
werden globale dienste sein und darauf
oder daneben werden sie einen lokalen
einschlag haben aber was ich sehe zum
beispiel sind es die block zehn projekte
die registrierung von diplomen werden
jetzt von den ländern selbst gemacht ich
erwarte dass dies eine globale
oberfläche wird wir bringen menschen aus
all diesen koalitionen und all diesen
gemeinschaften zusammen um an diesen
herausforderungen zu arbeiten die
hauptsächlich globale herausforderungen
sind und ich denke im moment ist der
erste schritt diese experten
zusammenzubringen sie brauchen einander
zum beispiel die block zehn experten sie
brauchen mehr und mehr daten und deshalb
brauchen sie die experten aus der big
data arbeitsgruppe aber auch die
datenexperten aus der arbeitsgruppe für
künstliche intelligenz der nächste
schritt ist also der aufbau von sub
kooperationen weltweit und ich hoffe
dass die niederlande für viele dienste
das tor zu europa sein können
die zukunft der staatlichen
dienstleistungen sollte etwas sein das
geschieht ohne dass der kunde danach
fragt wir wissen was die kunden wollen
warum geben wir es ihnen nicht warum
gehen wir nicht zum kunden anstatt einen
kunden zu uns kommen zu lassen wir
wollen es mehr mit der digitalen
erfahrung in verbindung bringen die
kunden heute beim online-shopping haben
wo sie empfehlungen bekommen was sie
kaufen sollen basierend auf ihren
vorherigen suchen auf der jahreszeit wir
wollen so ähnlich sein und vielleicht
sogar noch proaktiver wir sind uns
bewusst dass sich die art und weise wie
bildung vermittelt werden soll ändern
wird wir sind uns bewusst dass sich das
gesundheitswesen verändern wird all
diese dienstleistungen müssen auf eine
art und weise integriert werden dies für
den kunden nahtlos macht
wir haben die meisten unserer dienste
bereits online gestellt aber jetzt geht
es darum die qualität der dienste
tatsächlich zu messen wie funktionieren
sie was könnte verbessert werden was ist
der weg dahinter das meiste kann man
online machen aber wir haben immer noch
viele relikte dabei als wir in estland
unserer dienste für nicht bürger mit der
residenz sie geöffnet haben fiel auf
dass ausländern von zeit zu zeit von
unseren systemen einige ist mische
dokumente angezeigt wurden das ist etwas
das überarbeitet werden muss wir
arbeiten auf die vorstellung hin
nahtlose hintergrund dienste zu haben
sobald sie geboren werden kennen wir
bereits ihren namen wir kennen ihr
geburtstag wir wissen eine ganze reihe
von dingen über sie dasselbe gilt zum
beispiel für die medizin wir sehen uns
einige möglichkeiten an mit denen wir
vorher sagen können welche krankheiten
sie haben könnten oder ob sie genetisch
bedingt sind und ähnliches
wir waren sehr pragmatisch und haben
gesagt lasst uns herausfinden wie wir
dieses problem lösen können
organisatorisch rechtlich ohne dass wir
dabei sicherheitsvorkehrungen für die
technologie verletzten es ist ein sehr
ingenieur mäßiger weg und zum anderen
haben wir von der tatsache profitiert
dass wir in diesem sinne offensichtlich
ein kleines land sind die größe spielt
nicht wirklich eine rolle in dem
gesichtspunkt wie viele menschen dort
leben ich würde sagen dass wir als
kleines land eine sehr schlanke
regierung haben was die art und weise
betrifft wie entscheidungen getroffen
werden wenn mich die länder fragen ok
warum ist island ein bisschen flinker
sage ich weil die entscheidungsfindung
schneller ist und nicht zu viele
regierungsebenen konsultiert werden
müssen und so weiter und ich habe auch
in größeren ländern gesehen dass wenn
einige entscheidungsprozesse gestrafft
werden natürlich in einem demokratischen
kontext man dann auch größere sprünge
machen kann da sich die technik schnell
weiterentwickelt müssen sie auch
schneller mit ziehen können
[Musik]
was die welt wirklich verändern wird ist
wenn aufgeklärte progressiven
regierungen in der lage sind sich leicht
mit aufgeklärten aktiven bürgern zu
verbinden denn das ist eine starke kraft
wenn sie diese beiden dinge
zusammenbringen können wir einige
wirklich erstaunliche dinge tun diese
art von spannung die zwischen gemeinden
und regierungen besteht weil die
gemeinden große erwartungen haben dass
die regierungen sich anstrengen aber sie
kämpfen damit diese erwartungen zu
erfüllen in einer digitalen welt können
sie konsistenter liefern und zugang zu
informationen und daten erhalten wenn
sie benötigt werden sie schaffen einen
nahtlosen kanal zwischen den daten die
von der regierung erstellt oder
gesammelt werden und dem wunsch darauf
zuzugreifen einfach weil wir wissen
wollen was die regierung über uns
sammelt aber auch um bessere
entscheidungen treffen und lösungen
entwickeln zu können
die world in zukunft wird es einen viel
höheren grad an automatisierung geben
und das wird sowohl in der digitalen
welt also dem einsatz von künstlicher
intelligenz aber auch durch robotics
sein und sie werden sich fragen dazu
ergeben was das für die menschliche
erfahrung bedeutet was bedeutet das für
arbeitsplätze was bedeutet das für die
persönliche verbindung zwischen eine
person und einem anbieter wir werden
also alle positiven seiten der
automatisierung und der künstlichen
intelligenz sehen wir müssen uns auch
bewusst sein was das letztlich für uns
als menschen bedeutet wir müssen
entscheiden wie wir damit umgehen wollen
in den nächsten zehn bis 20 jahren wird
es mehr veränderungen geben als in den
letzten 100 jahren wenn es um regierungs
erlebnisse geht das wird eine
bemerkenswerte zeit
all die verschiedenen methoden die heute
zur verfügung stehen einschließlich des
checks programms sind erstaunlich sie
können verändern wie bürger bedient
werden sie können die art und weise
verändern wie bürger wie sie und ich
zugang zu dienstleistungen auf
regierungsebene in dem land unserer wahl
haben ich glaube wirklich dass
regierungen gx als ein programm
betrachten müssen dass frischen wind
bringen das effizienz- und
verantwortlichkeit in ihrer regierung
bringen kann
[Musik]
die vereinten nationen sagen voraus dass
die weltbevölkerung bis 2050 98
milliarden menschen erreichen wird das
bedeutet dass mehr wartung in den
regierungen gestellt werden um den
bürger besser zu dienen und bessere
erfahrungen zu schaffen das bedeutet
eine komplexere welt mit neuen
interessensgruppen neuen
herausforderungen und neuen
reaktionsgeschwindigkeiten im jahr 2020
kämpfte die menschheit mit einer neuen
herausforderung der korona pandemie
viele regierungen hatten probleme im
umgang mit der pandemie und auch gelang
es vielen über die erwartungen hinaus
die bedrohung durch die pandemie zu
kontrollieren und zu beseitigen eine
sache die alle reaktionsschnellen und
erfolgreichen regierungen auszeichnete
war ihre fähigkeit schnell zu reagieren
mit den bürgern in kontakt zu treten und
sich auf den erfolg zu konzentrieren und
gleichzeitig in die zukunft zu blicken
es sind diese regierungen denker führer
und wegbereiter die dabei sind eine
bessere welt zu schaffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn sie glauben dass es einen
gesellschaftsvertrag zwischen den
regierten und der regierung gibt dann
müssen die regierungen bei der
bereitstellung von dienstleistungen
berücksichtigen was die menschen
wirklich von dieser beziehung haben
wollen
[Applaus]
manchmal funktioniert die lösung die an
einem ort funktioniert an einem anderen
ort nicht ich denke es ist eine echte
führungsqualität aktion wenn man sehr
neugierig auf die geschichte und die
kulturen ist in denen man arbeitet um
die dienstleistungen auf die jeweiligen
bewohner oder bürger abzustimmen denen
man dient
der ansatz dienstleistungen von außen
nach innen und nicht von innen nach
außen zu erbringen bedeutet einen
paradigmenwechsel in der art und weise
wie die regierung traditionell politik
entwickelt und dann über die erbringung
von dienstleistungen nachdenkt
die herausforderungen mit denen
regierungen konfrontiert sind sind nicht
mehr technischer natur die sind gelöst
die probleme mit denen regierungen heute
konfrontiert sind drehen sich eher um
raffinierte probleme wie zum beispiel
die fragen wie lösen wir obdachlosigkeit
wie können wir die
lebensmittelversorgung verbessern wie
können wir die lebensqualität der
menschen verbessern wir begannen mit der
öffentlichen politik und konzentrierten
uns sehr auf märkte und marktversagen
und wie die regierung probleme durch
marktversagen lösen musste ich denke das
ist immer noch eine wichtige sache aber
ich denke wir müssen jetzt darüber
hinausgehen und verstehen dass
gleichheit und gerechtigkeit wirklich
wichtige faktoren sind die wir
berücksichtigen müssen es gibt orte die
sich bei der erbringung digitaler
dienstleistungen hervor tun aber ich
habe noch keine regierung gesehen die
dann die daten im backend für kunden
einblicke für prädiktive analysen
raumbezogene analysen und wirkliche
leistungsoptimierung verwendet nur weil
sie einen großen umfangreichen datensatz
haben heißt das nicht zwangsläufig dass
er ihnen in irgendeiner weise helfen
kann wenn sie keinen wert oder keine
informationen aus diesen rohdaten
erschließen können die art und weise wie
ich darüber nachdenke wie die regierung
eine rolle spielen kann besteht darin
sich wirklich auf informationen zu
konzentrieren die für die wähler die
politischen entscheidungsträger die
bürger die einwohner oder die besucher
wertvoll sind und diese informationen zu
nutzen daraus zu lernen und zu
integrieren
ich denke die kunden haben erwartungen
die sich drastisch von dem unterscheiden
was regierungen heute an
dienstleistungen anbieten und wir
sollten die lücke schließen ich mache
mir gedanken darüber dass wir in einem
abschwung noch effizienter sein müssen
in der art wie wir dienen mit der
ausweitung der digitalen dienste müssen
wir darüber nachdenken wie wir
altmodische dienste auf eine neue art
durchführen eine sache die wir innerhalb
einer stadt tun kann sich auf den
verkehr auswirken was sich auf den
wohnungsbau auswirken kann was sich auf
die migration von menschen auswirken
kann wir müssen alles innerhalb der
systeme und innerhalb der größeren
mechanismen betrachten und nicht nur
einzelne entscheidungen
stellen sie sicher dass sie die richtige
führung haben denn sie können nicht
innovativ sein wenn das ein jahr dauert
bis ein business case für einen neuen
service genehmigt wird
[Musik]
eine sache auf die sich die regierung in
erster linie konzentrieren muss ist der
versuch die gemeinschaft zu verstehen
und zwar auf der mikroebene einer stadt
und der einsatz von technologie ist eine
möglichkeit dies zu tun aber auch die
fähigkeit sich tief in die
gemeinschaften einzubetten um die
größten herausforderungen zu verstehen
mit denen die menschen konfrontiert sind
und dann in der lage zu sein diese daten
auf eine weise zu nutzen die tatsächlich
veränderungen bewirken kann diese
nächste generation sorgt sich mehr um
den planeten um fragen zur ungleichheit
als frühere generationen ich denke wir
müssen die regierungen für sie attraktiv
machen
[Musik]